بس هي تريد سريعا ان تريد سريعا ان يؤمن
لها مسكن اقله مبدئي من جهه الخيام وايضا
من جهه المبيت من جهه الطعام وايضا من جهه
تامين التدفئه بالاضافه ايضا الى المقلب
الاخر هي الاستمرار بعمليات الانقاذ اذا
بالامكان نرجع نشوف الصور من خلفك ومن
جانبك بينما تتحدث محمود اذا سمحت اذا كان
بالامكان
مدينه
عمنقتها يعني عن التركي الذي لا اعلم هو
مدى المساحه التي عليها ولكن المدينه التي
نحن فيها وبها هي بالملايين والعدد
المفقود ايضا بالالاف القتلى والضحايا
بالالاف الجرح ايضا بالالاف الاطقم التي
تصل من متطوعين هي ايضا بالالاف لذلك
البعض الذي يتحدث عن حاجه ضروريه وملحه
وماسه من الحكومه للقيام به هو محق في هذه
المساله ولكن هنا نتحدث نحن عن قدرات
ونتحدث ايضا عن امكانياتنا نتحدث ايضا عن
اعداد المنطق الهادئ لربما نحن نحتاج الى
اكثر من 100 الف شخص منظمين كجيش باكمله
او برمته ان ينزل على الارض وعلى مدار 24
ساعه لتنظيم
المناطق ربما الموضوع خارج قدره اي حكومه
في في امام مثل هذا
اذا كان بالامكان اذكر اذا كان بالامكان
محمود ان نشاهد يعني المشاهد في الجانبيه
لعمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه التي تجري عندك
اذا كان بالامكان تقنيا
بينما تتحدث ايضا في هذا الموضوع اسالك
بالتزامن مع عدم قدره الحكومه على تلبيه
كل هذه المتطلبات ما هي الخيارات
الاسرع
والاكثر اقتصاديه التي يلجا اليها
المتضررون اذا من الذين تهدمت بيوتهم
تماما او الذين تضررت بيوتهم جزئيا او من
اولئك الذين كانوا خائفين من العوده الى
بيوتهم في الاوقات التي كانت فيها الهزات
الارتداديه مستمره وهي لا تزال مستمره في
الواقع
يعني سابدا معك من خ السؤال هو العوده الى
المنازل لا يمكن العوده الى المنازل
اطلاقا لانها غير صالحه للسكن الضرر الذي
اصابها هو بليغ وهو كبير جدا ويخاف ان هذه
الابنيه تسقط بين الفنيه والاخرى وغير
يمكن الدخول اليها من المشاهد المبكيه
التي حصلنا عليها والتي شاهدناها بالامس
كيف كان انه المراه او عائله تريد ان تحصل
على بطانيه وهي تقف امام البنايه او بعيده
عن البنايه التي عندها شقه على حوالي كيلو
متر او 500 متر ولا يمكن لهم ان يذهبوا
الى الحي فضلا عن ايضا الحديث الذي كان
بيننا وبين عدد كبير من المواطنين الذين
جاءوا هم يقولون عبر الكاميرا الى انهم
يريدون ان تتوجه فرق الالقاد الى هذه
الاحياء دون الاحياء الاخرى لان هنالك عدد
كبيره من الناس والمفقودين لا زالوا تحت
الانقاذ